yeah welcome to this video playing black
enough five oops in a five-minute game
against Grand Master Eric Lou Brown here
from Germany Yardbird it's one of the
most frequent um players on on icc and i
played played the bogo indian
interesting yeah maybe this castling was
a bit early yes so it feels like
relatively solid position I need to be
cautious that I am I take on now on c3
after he castles I need to take if I
don't do this now we might move this
night away and then my head my bishop on
before sir we were stranded peace the
problem here is that is may be ready to
play a for now f4 and f1 4 and so on and
unfortunately this is exactly the type
of position in which she plays really
great chess I mean it is a very good
player and dynamic and dumb and and
technically complicated position and
this is what we got now in fact I like
it that he played f4 instantly this I
think helps me a bit it's not like it's
great now but it helped me I think so
rookie aid because i got there i got the
efr now for possible counter play and
it's not like I'm being run
well now I think something like g4s
probably just just to lose rookie three
years what I'd like to play maybe rookie
3 enter yeah this is a typical IDM
intending to take on 97 and damaging my
pawn structure but I couldn't really am
prevent it I thought okay so um I can
play Queenie seven Queenie 70 maybe he's
got rookie one rookie you wanted then
Queen to f8 it's very personal yeah okay
but I don't have fun great move anyway I
think and maybe it's not so terrible I'm
I prepare Queen to f8 everything else
fails yeah I thought I can now how check
I can play forgot about that Queen III I
can play Bishop f2 I thought I have to
send a media check in okay it's probably
not so so terrible this this more
information well maybe it is but maybe
it's not so it's not winning immediately
King to age 7 and then hope for the best
on the gphone he can play a d5 of course
yes but I've got fcat rook g8 and so on
maybe rook GA doesn't even the best move
what does I can play look at four right
yeah I wants to go look at form hmm how
do I am I can play roop she ate but then
then d5 my bishop is really a terrible
piece
thinking about d5 p.m. summer I want to
I want to prevent him to play d5 to shut
out my bishop immediately Luke g8 d5 I
could play c6 another 90 for some not
nice at all okay need to need to move at
some at some point 94 now yeah probably
hook g54 sir wasn't exactly great
okay try to counter check on on c4 so 94
I can i take i take c form and now i can
he can play this even Knight f6 and
ropey item is the problem yeah with the
terrible game time yeah okay I can of
course just resign that I'd really don't
think that this is so bad for me would
be and I don't know you cannot believe
really i mean this this is just too
simplistic cannot cannot be a too great
for wide I just need to just need
precise movie I feel with one or two
precise moves that this isn't too great
for white I mean not like bad for white
but I mean it should be playable he says
he needs some time to to get pieces on
the king and if I'm not meted a player
stupidly as in the game then it
shouldn't be too terrible
yeah the computer just wants to go
rookie three I consider this briefly in
the game but with an equal position by
the way I was thinking about this the
idea being rookie three and Queenie
seven but ok again this is this is
problematic will create rock g8 really
was bad I probably really need to go
here I need to let's just check this I
don't think that this what he did f4
says right i mean that it helps me so I
feel I should I should be okay rookie
three you see his guts also some
weaknesses and it's not like it's a
complete one way street in this position
let's say here and then maybe Queen to
e7 or work g8 first I don't know twin
Queenie same name if he goes look at 4i
can play em maybe looking to for example
threatening queen III and it's I'm not
clear what what you should do now really
I move like this I don't know can easily
backfire then I don't know yeah this is
a fight i mean i'm not sure what what it
is it's like it's like coke complicated
and chances I mean for both sides but it
certainly would have been better in the
game where I just got completely
destroyed yeah thanks for watching this
boy